the lockdown in Spain is slowly being
eased in Madrid some non-essential
workers trudged onto the metro system
where they were met by police handing
out face masks the government is
allowing people from some sectors like
construction industry and
telecommunications back to work but the
stay at home orders for most remain in
place the situation we had was my
stricter than were any other country and
we believe that we should not confront
economy and health the corner verasun
the crises going to have the number of
deaths every day is still in the
hundreds but over the last week the grim
figures have started to fall at the
emergency response hub in Madrid they're
still dealing with a daily flood of
coronavirus calls for maybe a blink
blink class like ten years ago but they
just let go into a moment or one day to
date but some say the true awfulness of
this pandemic is still hidden as only
those dying in hospital are included in
the official figures military disaster
teams are delivering supplies and
checking on care homes where it's feared
many elderly people have died from the
virus
the surreal nosov the crisis is
difficult to comprehend in Barcelona
iconic sites are deserted and the RAM
blasts which is always swollen with
throngs of tourists is empty it is still
very quiet here in Barcelona in
Catalonia Easter Monday is a public
holiday across this region but there are
concerns across Spain from regional
leaders and trade unions that
central government's decision to ease
the lockdown could backfire the fear is
that there could be a secondary outbreak
of infections and that could have
devastating consequences for a
healthcare system that is already
overwhelmed this debate about lives
versus livelihoods will continue for
weeks to come as scientific experts and
the government tried to balance the
public health impact against the damage
to the economy in fact the reality is
that life here like elsewhere in Europe
is unlikely to normalize for many months
and that means please checkpoint to
control movements until most likely a
vaccine is found Alex Rossi Sky News
Barcelona